und die ereignisse überschlagen sich
meine damen und herren gestern
nachmittag breaking news armin laschet
haut in sachsen sich zurück geht in den
ruhestand
respekt denkt man so konsequenter
schritt wenn man bedenkt welche
demütigungen die union den mann
zugemutet hat irgendwann ist auch mal
gut und natürlich wollten alle sender
live dabei sein wenn im
konrad-adenauer-haus
weltgeschichte geschrieben wird um 18 30
wird ein statement erwartet von armin
laschet am el assad seine bereitschaft
für einen rückzug angekündigt bei der
union da geht es richtig rund was wird
uns jetzt erwacht das ist eine ziemliche
bombe wie ein ventil das jetzt platzt
armin laschet will sich offenbar
zurückziehen da ist armin laschet und
wir signalisieren
fdp und grünen
ansprechpartner für die cdu bleibt der
cdu vorsitzende
aber wer ist cdu-vorsitzender du doch
wohl nicht mehr wie jetzt doch noch
was war das denn wirklich ich bin seit
gestern 18 30 ununterbrochen verwirrt
und ich war nicht der einzige aber armin
laschet hat damit einen geschickten
schachzug dennoch in die partei hinein
zumindest
gemacht also hatte einen pflock ein baum
hat nämlich an der latte hoch gelegt
oder so irgendjemand hat eine latte auf
den flop gelegt laschets botschaft er
denkt darüber nach demnächst vielleicht
zu erwägen sich zurückzuziehen wenn das
gewünscht wird so langsam wird es
wirklich tragisch freunde seit dieser
woche ist doch jedem klar die ampel
kommt höchstwahrscheinlich die ampel
quetscht sich durch den geburtskanal
armin da macht es keinen sinn mehr die
fdp weiter anzubaggern das nennt man
stalking guck mal wie dicke die alle
schon miteinander sind da war es schon
so weit dass christian lindner annalena
baerbock eine antwort zuflüsterte
und bei ihr klang das dann so
wir sind heute schmallippig auch dazu
können wir heute nichts weiteres sagen
interessant oder bernburg laut einfach
den text vom lindner sie kann's nicht
lassen ich meine klar könnte die ampel
auch noch scheitern da reicht ein
falsches interview weshalb ich der spd
ja dringend tragen würde esken und
walter borjans weiter gut zu verstecken
ja ja einfach nur um sicherzugehen klar
die ampel wäre keine liebesheirat aus
fdp sicht eher eine zwangsehe
zwangsehe weil sich der wunschpartner
union derweil selber zerstört wie
unfassbar gnadenlos dieser verein ist am
mittwoch werden ampel sondierung
offiziell verkündet und der tapfere
kleine armin sagt unverdrossen wir
stehen bereit als gesprächspartner cdu
und csu
wir haben jetzt in klarheit das heute
war eine klare vorfestlegung von grünen
und fdp und de facto eine absage an
jamaika
cdu/csu sozialer als das sommer aus der
stars armin laschet sitzt er jetzt auf
gepackten koffern und wo natürlich
wahrscheinlich selber dass er noch im
amt ist wirklich wer sollte mit dieser
union noch sanieren wollen wenn du mit
denen verhandelt wird ständig alles
mögliche gelegt durch gestochen die fdp
war stinksauer zurecht natürlich werde
jetzt genau geplaudert hat das weiß man
ja das sind ja 15 leute um union stil so
gesehen könnte dass praktisch jeder
gewesen sein da verbietet sich jede
spekulation ist ja klar
gelegt wurde unter anderem dass die
liberalen zur union gesagt haben ihr
müsst die grünen zitat rüberziehen wie
soll das denn funktionieren die grünen
rüberziehen obwohl warte man klar du
längst habeck mit irgendwas ab was für
ihn unwiderstehlich ist also zum
beispiel mit einem fotoshooting und bei
berbalk müsste die union wahrscheinlich
mit chloroform arbeiten kann man sie
rüber ziehen und anschließend
unterschreibt oper kretschmann den
jamaika koalitionsvertrag fertig geht
doch merke ich gerade keiner weiß als
ungeklärt ist wie jetzt der neue cdu
chef bestimmt wird armin laschet oft es
gibt einen friedlichen übergang ohne
öffentliche machtkämpfe
ägypter die gxr wahnsinn mindestens drei
männer kämpfen um den parteivorsitz ja
das gibt es jetzt sogar als game cdu
street fighter das zocke ich seit tagen
ist großartig warte mal wen haben wir
dann weiter nummer 1 jens spahn bis vor
kurzem noch als verbündeter jetzt
todfeind kann sich aber über worten
wieder ändern spezialfähigkeit
geldverbrennen durch viel zu späten dann
aber absurd euren masken kauf kampfname
the golden master
2 norbert röttgen tritt immer an aber
keiner weiß warum spezialfähigkeit
verteufelt gut aussehen sonst absolut
nichts passt also super zur cdu
und er ist der einzige bundesminister
der jemals von angela merkel gefeiert
wurde cool und natürlich der älteste
fighter der ultra erfahrene friedrich
merz seine spezialfähigkeit er kann
tatsächlich durch die zeit reisen
allerdings nur zurück in die 90er
in total bescheuerte spiel wirklich man
ja märz und röttgen wollen eine
mitgliederbefragung um den neuen chef zu
bestimmen sparen er nicht weil er seine
umfragewerte kennt er kann ja lesen und
friedrich merz hätte ja auch noch eine
andere option wenn es durch eine
verkettung unglücklicher umstände
doch noch zu jamaika käme wäre er ein
möglicher finanzminister jaja märz der
große finanzexperte der neulich noch
behauptet hat unser bundeshaushalt
stecke wegen der gestiegenen
neuverschuldung in einer
liquiditätsfalle
worauf sich die echten experten tage
lang kaputt gelacht haben märz
grundschul wissen
das bruttoinlandsprodukt der kannst du
schon echt so ein lager vorschlag du
spielst du dein flugzeit
finanzministers ludwig er hat das alles
nicht mehr erleben muss aber was wird
jetzt aus deutschlands letzter
volkspartei der guten alten cdu wir
schalten live zu unserer reporterin
birte schneider vor dem konrad adenauer
haus in berlin wird was passiert gerade
oliver wie soll man das beschreiben
chaos hoffnungslosigkeit
verzweiflung sie sehen es ja in manchen
büros werden schon akten verbrannt ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen solche bilder
habe ich nicht mehr gesehen seit dem
fall von bagdad
das geht aber rasant bergab ja klar
zusammengehalten wurde diese partei seit
jahren nur noch durch regieren weil sie
ämter verteilen konnte jetzt wo die
opposition droht haben viele innerhalb
von minuten auf drogendealer umgeschult
das ist ganz lieb aber heute möchte ich
kein christ auch kein speed 4 danke
schön
traurig sind einfach nur fertig hamm sie
gehört was der chef der hamburger cdu
letzten sonntag ernsthaft in der ard
gesagt hat er meint konservative
parteien in europa schwächeln aber aber
es gibt auch gute beispiele wie zb in
österreich
da ist die partner partei wieder nach
oben gekommen mit einem klaren kurs
outdoor aus österreich und kanzler kurz
als vorbild genau vier tage später gibt
es im kanzleramt in wien eine
hausdurchsuchung ermittelt wird gegen
sebastian kurz und sein engstes umfeld
wegen des verdachts der untreue
bestechung und bestechlichkeit
geiles cdu vorbild der vorwurf umfragen
und berichte der tageszeitung österreich
seien durch steuergeld gekauft und das
kannst du warst ein kurzes live im
studio und freut sich riesig drauf
übrigens auch der chef der jungen union
tillmann kuban hat neulich in einem
interview gesagt cdu vorbild sei
österreich wo es zitat sebastian kurz
auch als konservativer politiker
schaffen bei den jüngeren auf platz 1 zu
liegen bitte kurz ist in seinem land
ursprünglich auf platz eins gelandet
weil er mit der spd koaliert hat das
wäre bei uns die afd mal abwarten wo ist
die cdu noch so hinführt irgendeinen
marken kann braucht man ja wenn man kein
meer hat
[Gelächter]
hausdurchsuchung im kanzleramt was da
bei uns los wäre stellen sie sich mal
vor bei olaf scholz
schlechtes beispiel wahnsinn und wie
geht es jetzt weiter mit dem ex cdu idol
sebastian kurz na ja zum glück haben
seine eltern das kinderzimmer noch nicht
ausgeräumt es gibt also einen weg zurück
wenn er in ein paar tagen sagt ich will
nicht mehr ich kann nicht mehr ich halte
das alles nicht mehr aus ja man kann
wirklich nur hoffen dass die cdu aus dem
debakel von wien die richtigen schlüsse
zieht
rechtsruck ist keine lösung vor allem
wenn man gerade hauptsächlich wähler an
grüne und spd verloren
ach du scheiße jetzt fängt die junge
union auch noch mit plündern an das war
klar birte schneider
ab montag heißt es gibt es in berlin
vertiefte ampel sondierung aber selbst
wenn das jetzt alles überraschend
schnell geht ein paar wochen
verhandlungen liegen mindestens für uns
heißt da kommen noch allerhand schlimme
wortspiele aller für die ampel stehen
die zeichen auf grün auf und zu ja
müssen wir jetzt durch
irgendwer mit medien mit friedrich
küppersbusch
die schlechte nachricht ich habe keine
es gibt keine schlechte nachrichten die
verhandlung um eine neue regierung
scheinen zu laufen bauen was hatten wir
für den horror gehabt von diesem
sondierungs journalismus da hat man ja
nun mal nichts zu melden und tut den
ganzen tag manchmal wochenlang ist eine
tolle überhaupt niemand gaal und stand
deswegen ist die mikrofone und ständer
kriegen wir sehen im moment dass sehen
sind natürlich selbst einfach nur einen
leeren raum und die mikrofone letztes
mal führte dieses endlosen nichts zu
diesen berüchtigten balkon eskalationen
wir haben extra ein ort gewählt wo es
keinen balkon gibt denn das war sogar
den politikern kann ich meine jetzt
können das ja sagen die haben damals
immer mehr verhandelt die haben drin nur
noch gelobt innichen gezogen wer als
nächster raus muss um den medien auf dem
balkon eine kleine show nummer
anzubieten volker kauder zum beispiel
wollte eine eigene montagabend sendung
in der sich jens spahn immer gegen die
stoppuhr die socken richten muss damals
hat prosieben das format abgelehnt heute
werden sie froh drüber ein weiteres
typisches merkmal das sondiert tainment
ist die grundsätzliche anwesenheit von
claudia roth man nennt sie auch den
tumor marker des nichts wir sehen also
dort wieder eine limousine vorgefahren
und während aus stein claudia roth die
aktuelle vize präsidentin des deutschen
bundestages und so überraschend wie um
ein beispiel zu nennen claudia roth sind
die buzzwords bei den statements der
politiker sie können diesen in diesem
lager käse oder anderes herz glauben sie
dass die in destruktiven gegeneinander
lustige themen besprechen wir haben in
konstruktiven miteinander ernste themen
besprochen ja all komas doch ganz schön
alt geworden nein das ist natürlich
volker wissing ein sympathischer
liberaler der halt nach feierabend
privat gern der kleidung trägt und was
bei ihm klingt wie das übliche bullshit
bingo ist in wirklichkeit ein geheimcode
es wird wieder gefroren vor gebäuden in
denen geredet wird die journalistin
frieren wissen möchte so viel sendezeit
wie möglich also haben die gewettet
jedes mal beim bissingen auf dem sender
konstruktiv miteinander oder ernste
themen sagt dürfen die kollegen sich in
crock weg löten ist kann tote geben
übrigens hatten sich auch die
moderatorinnen und moderatoren super gag
für sondiert ausgedacht leider alle den
gleichen es war so ein bisschen wie
speed dating das speed dating der
parteien es hatte ein bisschen was von
speed-dating alles erinnert ein bisschen
an speed dating nach speed dating speed
date speed dating speed dating speed
dating einen parteispendenskandal
robert habeck ist ja würden sich ruhig
schon mal dran also robert habeck
versprach gestern abend es könne
womöglich sogar unter 10 sondierungs
fragen bleiben zügige entscheidung statt
des gefürchteten sondierungs
journalismus oder wie angela merkel
sagen würde das ist nicht mehr mein land
irgendwer mit medien mit friedrich
küppersbusch
[Musik]
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
info box neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]